all right today we learn we learn how to
teach girls how to smoke cigarettes here
Lola we're gonna turn this cigarette
into a knife first thing you do look
it's no prison trick I learned
there's nothing Rikers we didn't take
the writer set on fire
let's burn for a few seconds till it
gets nice and black and perfect you put
on something flat you want to smoosh it
as flat as you can as hard as you can
I hope this pass is flat enough we'll
see
so once it's drying you have a little
mini knife used to cut things or you can
just get your home cooks but anyway who
knew
you know it's actually pretty sharp you
can actually almost shave your hair's
not good right